-Hello, everyone,
and welcome back to the attic.
I've been sittin' here
for about a half an hour,
waiting for my neighbor
to stop mowing his lawn,
but don't worry.
I've been passing the time
trying to remember
how much we paid
for the tiny chair behind me,
which, to my knowledge,
neither of my children
ever, ever use.
Because it turns out,
toddlers rarely say,
"I don't know about you, but,
I need to take a load off."
Maybe I can get the dog
to sit in it?
Maybe that would be cute
and I could Instagram it
or you could Instagram it.
Truth is,
I think the chair is useless.
Speaking of useless,
that whole thing was a segue.
The Trump administration
understands
the importance of testing
to safely reopen the economy,
because they're
testing themselves.
They just don't care
about testing you.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Suspenseful theme plays ]
Donald Trump doesn't just lie
about the big things.
He also lies compulsively
about the smallest,
dumbest things,
like how many people were
at his inauguration
or who drew a circle
on a hurricane map
or whether he's ever
even met Eric and Don Jr.
"I'm sorry.
I'm not acquainted
with these two charming
business lizards."
And the lies
about the small stuff
are red flags for the
lies about the big stuff.
For example, Trump visited
a Honeywell factory
in Arizona Tuesday,
where they were making masks.
You might remember the trip
from this indelible image
of Trump inspecting the masks
while "Live and Let Die"
blasted in the background.
[ "Live and Let Die" plays ]
-The material
that traps the particulates --
[ Drowning out speaker ]
-♪ Live and let die ♪
♪♪
-My favorite part of that clip
is how oblivious Trump is
to what's going on around him.
He's just nodding
and pointing at a mask
like a tourist
at a museum that's on fire.
"They say she has that smile
because she likes
the smell of smoke."
But you might notice, based
on seeing his whole face,
that he is not, in fact,
wearing a mask
and, yet, when he spoke
to reporters on Wednesday,
he insisted he did,
in fact, wear a mask.
-Mr. President, yesterday,
you went to Arizona
and you had said,
before the trip,
that you would likely wear
a mask at the mask factory.
You ended up not wearing one.
-Well, I actually did
have one, no.
I put a mask on, yeah.
I had a mask on
for a period of time.
-We didn't see you
with a mask on.
-Well, I can't help it
if you didn't see me.
I mean, I had a mask on,
but I didn't need it.
But I did put a mask on
and it was a Honeywell mask,
actually.
And I also had a 3M mask and I
had about four other masks.
But I did have it on. I don't
know if you saw it or not,
but I had it on.
-How long did you have it
on for?
-Not too long, but I had it on.
I had it on backstage.
-Okay. First of all,
it's a factory.
[ Laughing ]
There's not a backstage.
"Let's give those machines
everything they've
bargained for, boys!"
[ Laughing ] Also, to Trump,
everything's a beauty pageant.
He was probably expecting the
machinists to be wearing sashes.
"Hi, I'm Ted from Tucson
and, well,
I guess my talent is --
[ Mumbling ] I don't know.
Makin' masks."
[ As Trump ] Very good, Ted.
Now, do a twirl.
Okay. And, now,
can we see the swimsuit
portion of the factory?
Is that nearby?
Second, what do you mean,
you can't help it
if we didn't see you?
We saw you.
You weren't wearing a mask.
You were wearing goggles,
which is notable
because it's very weird to see
a renowned moron like Trump
wearing something
a scientist wears in a lab.
It's like watching a dog
use a calculator.
[ Thumping ]
[ As dog ]
[ Grumbles ]
Well, there's something
much more revealing
about this episode
than just the fact
that the president
is a compulsive liar.
Trump didn't need to wear a mask
because he and all
the people around him
have been tested
for coronavirus,
which is obviously
quite the luxury,
a luxury most Americans
don't have.
White House Press Secretary
Kayleigh McEnany
was asked why
ordinary Americans
don't deserve the same
access to testing
that government officials
and corporate executives get
and she mocked the idea
of widespread testing as absurd.
-You said, at Honeywell,
that the president was told
by the folks at Honeywell,
as was the team,
that they didn't need
to wear masks.
The reason he was told that
is because
the people who would be
interacting with him
had all been tested and had
been shown to be negative
before that took place,
I guess.
So, the president
had those circumstances.
Obviously, he's the president,
but why shouldn't all Americans
who go back to work
be able to get a test
before they do it,
to feel comfortable
in their own work environment,
to be interacting
with other individuals?
-Yeah, well, let's dismiss
a myth about tests right now.
If we tested every
single American
in this country at this moment,
we'd have to retest them
an hour later
and then an hour later
after that because,
at any moment,
you could theoretically
contract this virus,
so the notion that
everyone needs to be tested
is just simply nonsensical.
-Oh, good point.
Maybe we should also stop
providing food, too,
because people will eat a meal
and then, four hours later,
they're just gonna
eat another meal.
Or under quarantine
20 minutes later.
But listen to what she's
saying there.
She's saying you don't need
to be tested to go back to work,
but the president and everyone
around him need to get tested
so he can go back to work safely
and freely engage
in all his favorite hobbies,
like shakin' hands
and touchin' his face,
coughin' onto other people,
and licking chip dust
off doorknobs.
[ As Trump ]
Did somebody eat Cheetos?
There's a real Cheeto vibe
from the doorknob.
That's what this is all about.
They just wanna
protect themselves,
while telling you
that you need to be a warrior
and get back out there
to get the economy going,
fires be damned.
They're all
Billy Zane from "Titanic,"
shoving themselves
through the crowd
to get onto a lifeboat,
while the rest of us float
in frigid waters
and cling to a door
that Rose probably
coulda let us in on,
because, you know,
there's clearly enough room.
It's like, "Oh, I'm sorry.
Is this a business class door?
Did you pay
for more leg room?"
I know.
I'm sorry, Rose. I know.
You've been through a lot.
But I digress.
The point is, they're lookin'
out for themselves, not you.
That's why they're
testing themselves
and stuffing bailout money
into the pockets
of big corporations
and the wealthy.
In fact, today, it was reported
that the CDC had even written
guidelines for safely reopening,
but the White House buried them.
The Trump administration
has shelved the document,
created by the nation's
top disease investigators,
with step-by-step advice
to local authorities
on how and when
to reopen restaurants
and other public places
during the still-raging
coronavirus outbreak.
That's right,
the CDC wrote a plan
for safely reopening
the economy
and the Trump administration
covered it up.
Basically,
they did to the CDC plan
what Dr. Fauci does to his face
during Trump's briefings.
[ As Trump ]
Oh, that's a good idea, Fauci.
I didn't know you could use
your hand as a mask.
[ Whispering ]
Jared! Jared!
Get me a patent for hand masks.
That way, the next time
Fauci does it,
he'll have to pay me
and I can keep makin' him do it
and he'll keep having
to make him pay me.
Ohhh! We're gonna
ruin him, Jared!
Ohh, we're gonna ruin Fauci!
[ Raises voice ]
Oh, hi, Fauci!
Oh, we were just talking
about you.
Weren't we, Jared?
[ Whispering ]
Jared, I'm winking.
Jared!
In fact, Trump even said
this week
he doesn't think we need
that much testing,
in order to get people back
into the workforce safely.
-Look, we have so much testing.
I don't think you need that kind
of testing, that much testing,
but some people disagree
with me.
Some people agree with me.
-No!
No one agrees with you.
I haven't seen one
public health official say,
"You know what?
Testing is overrated."
The importance
of widespread testing
is like the one thing
they all agree on.
If you watch the news, you will
hear the word testing enough
to have nightmares
about being back in high school.
Last night,
I woke up in a cold sweat
and yelled at my wife, "Honey!
I'm late for the PSATs!
Give me a practice test.
I need to cram!"
Or stuff.
It's a synonym.
Thanks, Kaplan!
Of course, Trump doesn't
understand tests
because he's never taken one
without cheating.
In college,
he just handed in blank essays
with a wad of cash
clipped to them
and a note that said,
"From Fred Trump."
So, Trump doesn't think
we need that much testing
or, at least, he doesn't think
you need that much testing.
He and everyone around him,
of course,
have a completely
different standard.
-Everybody traveling
has been tested.
We have great testing
and, literally, they've been
tested over the last hour
and the test result comes back
in five minutes.
We have great testing,
or they wouldn't be allowed
to travel with me,
so they're all tested,
everybody traveling
on the plane.
-Oh, I see.
So, ordinary Americans
being forced back to work
can't get tested,
but you and everyone
around you can.
Look, I get that he's
the president
and he's gonna get tested
before everyone else.
In fact, depending
on what the test is for,
I'd be fine with it.
I think everyone should have
access to COVID tests,
but I'd be okay with Trump
getting a regular CAT Stan
before he talks to the press.
Mr. President,
it looks like you have
what we in the medical
profession call
pancake brain.
But the point is not that the
president shouldn't get tested.
It's that, if he wants
to force working people back
into the economy prematurely
in the middle
of a deadly pandemic,
he should make sure everyone
else can get tested, too.
But Trump doesn't actually
care about that.
In fact, he went to the
Honeywell factory without a mask
to create the illusion
that everything is fine.
We can all get back to normal.
Because, as a showman,
there's nothing Trump loves more
than a photo op, or a prop.
Like the time he made a big deal
of personally redesigning
the color scheme
of Air Force One.
You know, important
president stuff.
And had a giant model
of the newer airplane
conspicuously placed on a table
in the Oval Office
during a meeting
with Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau.
Did you actually have
a federal employee
make you a toy airplane,
just so you could show it off
to a friend?
What's next, are you gonna
invite Kim Jong-un over
to watch you play Xbox
while you eat pizza rolls?
[ As Trump ] Yeah,
it's called "Rocket League."
Pretty cool.
I'd let you play,
but I only have one controller.
Mike!
We need more Totino's.
But, hey, I'm just glad Trump
has his priorities in order.
-Don't forget,
the cupboard was bare.
The other administration,
the last administration,
left us nothing.
-You're three years
into your first term.
-Yeah.
-You're now applying
for the job again.
What did you do,
when you became president,
to restock those cupboards
that you say were bare?
-Well, I'll be honest, uh...
I have a lotta things going on.
-You were playing
with a toy airplane.
Seriously,
how old are you, really?
I mean,
'cause your face says 90,
but your vocabulary says 9.
It's like body
is aging normally,
but his brain
is Benjamin Button-ing.
I mean, experts were warning
about a pandemic for years
and your big priority was
repainting your airplane.
If Trump weren't president,
he'd be
the dude airbrushing his van
down by Daytona Beach
during a hurricane.
You can just picture him
with a earring and a goatee,
gettin' interviewed
on the local news --
"Sir, why are you out here
during this deadly storm?!"
[ As Trump ] Well,
I gotta finish up the van.
I'm out, you know, puttin'
some privacy beads up
in the windows
and catch a snooze,
you know, I'm not selling
my trade goods on the pier.
You want a toy airplane?
It's also a bong.
And I also would like
that version of him.
In an alternate life,
I'm a big fan of that guy.
Also, it's not true
that the previous administration
left the cupboards bare.
You're the one
who repeatedly proposed cuts
to the budgets of agencies,
like the NIH and CDC,
shut down the
pandemic planning unit,
and ignored a briefing
from outgoing Obama officials
who tried to prepare you
for exactly this kind
of scenario
before your inauguration.
Of course, you couldn't attend
that pre-inauguration briefing
because you were too busy,
awkwardly bobbing your head
during a Three Doors Down
concert,
like a dad chaperoning his
14-year-old daughter on a date.
[ As Trump ]
Well! This band is great.
I guess you could say
they're my Kryptonite.
Oh, that, by the way,
is a reference
to a Three Doors Down song,
for those of you under 40.
No, let's face it -- almost all
of you over 40 as well.
Trump doesn't care or know
anything about testing
or contact tracing or pandemics.
[ Laughing ] He just loves
props and photo ops.
That's right, another one
of his trademark moves
is dramatically removing a piece
of paper from his coat pocket
and showing it off to reporters,
whether it's a letter
from a foreign leader
or a secret trade deal.
He's like an old lady
who cuts out
and mails articles
to her grandkids,
except he's too cheap
to spring for a stamp.
At any given time,
he's probably totin' around
like a week's worth of mail.
I think he's doing it so,
if he loses in November,
he can say he has
civil service protections.
[ As Trump ]
I'm technically a mailman,
so you can't fire me
without cause.
And, this week,
Trump has been doing it again.
Everywhere he goes, he's been
wavin' around a piece of paper
no one can read, or vet,
to support his claimed
that he's succeeding in ramping
up testing for coronavirus.
-These numbers
were just released
and this is the United States,
the amount of testing
and our level of testing
and the quality of testing.
So this is the testing
and the line here
is the United States.
If we tested as much as these
countries down here, okay?
Who don't do very much
testing at all,
if I tested this number
of people,
instead of this
number of people,
I'd have far fewer --
See this line?
Goes all the way up.
Over 7 million tests.
-No one can see or read
what you're holding.
Even the anchor can't read it.
He's sitting more
than 6 feet away from you.
Of course, he's probably
practicing social distancing.
Although, it's also possible
that's one
of the conditions
of Trump's work release.
"Donald, your probation
requires you
to stay at least 6 feet away
from everyone, at all times,
or your ankle monitor
will go off."
[ As Trump ]
Oh!
I thought that noise meant
the Totino's were done.
What a double burn for me --
no pizza rolls and,
I'm violating probation.
Double bur-r-r-n!
Of course, in reality,
wavin' around a piece of paper
means nothing.
The fact is Trump's deadly
incompetence has made us
the global epicenter
of the coronavirus outbreak,
while other major developed
countries have managed
to suppress the virus
and safely reopen.
And that failure is also due,
in large part,
to his translucent son-in-law,
Jared Kushner,
seen here showing off
his resting "the dean
will hear about this" face.
Kushner led a volunteer
task force
to oversee the White House
coronavirus response
and, it turns out --
wait for it --
was amazing
and did an incredible job
that impressed
public health experts
across the political spectrum
and I'm just [bleep] with you.
It was a disaster.
For example,
the task force was charged
with securing protective
equipment for hospitals,
but, according
to The New York Times,
few of the leads panned out.
They used personal
Gmail accounts,
prompting suspicion
from some prospective suppliers
and brokers who questioned
their bona fides.
That's right,
they were emailing people
from personal Gmail accounts,
trying to buy masks
and ventilators.
It's like they designed these
emails to go directly to spam.
Did their emails
ask for ventilators
and also offer suppliers
to help "meet hot horny
singles in your area"?
Don't accept the false dichotomy
between staying locked down
and reopening the economy.
There's a third option,
where we can safely reopen
and involves doing exactly
what Trump and his allies
are doing for themselves --
widespread testing.
But Trump and his allies
are only interested
in protecting themselves,
while they use you
as cannon fodder
to rev up the economy.
If you believe Trump,
or his toadies,
were ever really populace
champions of the working class,
it's only because
he tricked you.
I guess you could say he's...
-Had a mask on
for a period of time.
-This has been "A Closer" --
[ Gasp ]
Instagram it!
Talkin' to the chair!
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Once again, we're asking you
to help City Harvest.
You may have donated already,
but more and more New Yorkers
are turning to them
to keep food on their tables,
so, please give, if you can.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Wash your hands.
We love you.